[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans point de vue
votre émission de débat sur lefigaro.fr
une émission en direct diffusée sur
notre site que vous pouvez également
suivre en direct sur youtube j'attends
vos remarques et vos commentaires sur
nos deux sujets du jour remarques et
commentaires que je ne manquerai pas de
relayer tout à l'heure je vous présente
nos deux invités du jour bonjour pascal
perrault jour vous êtes politologue
professeur à sciences po et ancien
directeur du cevipof
vous venez de publier le populisme dans
la collection que sais-je aux presses
universitaires de france
bonjour guillaume tabard josette
éditorialiste politique au figaro
allez on démarre par notre premier sujet
emmanuel macron a accordé hier un long
entretien au figaro axé sur la sécurité
interview dans laquelle il affiche sa
fermeté et sa détermination il veut
faire reculer la délinquance partout je
me bats pour le droit à la vie paisible
at il déclaré et surtout on verra plus
de bleus sur le terrain en 2022 qu'en
2017 alors est-ce un début de campagne à
droite toute
pascal perrineau pourquoi emmanuel
macron par maintenant de ce sujet il
commença à se positionner pour 2022
bien sûr il trouve comme beaucoup de
français que si vous voulez un an de
lutte contre l'extension de la pandémie
c'est beaucoup et pour le futur candidat
qu'il est à l'élection présidentielle de
l'année prochaine
il ya besoin de sortir de ce tunnel qui
pour les français est sans fin quel
tunnel de la lutte contre la copie est
donc de tenter et on le voit depuis
quelques semaines différents ballons
d'essai pour dire il y aura un après et
le monde d'après va venir très vite
puisque ça va commencer avec les
régionales et départementales de jours
prochains et puis ensuite on va avoir en
effet la présidentielle qui d'ailleurs
déjà commencé à droite à gauche et bien
sûr dans le ni droite ni gauche ou dans
le et de droite et de gauche des manuels
macron et il sait très bien qu'il ya des
fragilités et ce président d'abord il
certes il est moins impopulaire que
françois hollande
il est un peu moins impopulaire à la
même période que nicolas sarkozy qui
avait perdu mais enfin il ne bat pas des
records de popularité
c'est un gros tiers de français qui
aujourd'hui 37% je crois dans le dernier
baromètre de l'ifop qui lui font qu'on
fait confiance donc ça ne sera pas
simple pour lui de construire cette
victoire il sait qu'il a des fragilités
il a allez mettons 23% 24% de fidèles
ils sont toujours là et qui après quatre
ans de mandat sont toujours au rendez
vous mais ça ne suffit pas pour faire 50
% et + et donc depuis de nombreux mois
maintenant
il regarde attentivement du côté de
l'électorat de droite pourquoi plus de
lecteurs à droite que lectorat de gauche
parce que l'électorat de gauche il est
pas en voie de disparition faut pas
exagérer mais il est très anémiée
l'électorat de droite ça existe et il y
à un nouveau candidat xavier bertrand
qui prétend représenter cet électorat de
droite et donc ils cherchent un peu si
vous voulez les thèmes qui pourraient
séduire fidéliser cet électorat de
droite et on sait très bien toutes les
enquêtes les plus récentes le montrent
que l'électorat de droite encore plus
parfois que l'électorat du rassemblement
national est très sensible au thème de
la sécurité de la montée de la
délinquance
or tous les électeurs de droite comme
d'ailleurs constate dans les derniers
mois une montée de la délinquance
extrêmement préoccupante et le président
c'est que là dessus il suffit de
regarder toutes les enquêtes en
particulier de l'ifop c'est que là
dessus il a beaucoup de chemin à faire
pour construire une crédibilité oui
dites moi guillaume tabard justement il
y avait urgence pour macron à se
positionner sur cette question de la
sécurité c'est vrai que l'ifop montre
que le chef de l'état a perdu 18% depuis
décembre chez son électorat de droite
oui a déclaré droite que qu'il avait
conquis en tout cas séduit en partie
essentiellement sur les thématiques
économiques et fiscales bon alors c'est
vrai que
pascal perrineau le rappeler cette
question là et arrive dans les priorités
très élevé dans lectorat de droite il
faut préciser que c'est la question la
sécurité est quand même une
préoccupation pour l'ensemble des
électorats y compris électorat de gauche
ont un peu tendance à dire que la
sécurité c'est la droite mais
l'électorat de gauche lui même est
attentif à ces questions là mais de
manière à dire sur éminente dans
l'électorat de droite donc élevées 7,7
nécessité et puis c'est vrai que ne faut
pas oublier ceux la crise du coc vide
que rappeler pascal
en ce moment on dire aux français de
quoi le président de ti de s'occuper les
gens répondront bien sûr de la pandémie
de nous sortir de là au plus vite
mais lorsqu'on a sorti et on peut même
espérer que mal finir par en sortir ou
pas c'est une question de semaines ou de
mois mais on va également sortir
là pour le coup il lui restera quand
même quelques semaines quelques mois
utiles et le président se rendra avec un
bilan global et si pendant toute cette
longue période cette longue parenthèse
pourrait-on dire
il n'a pas fait preuve de décision et
d'efficacité dans différents domaines
dont sur la sécurité
à ce moment on pourrait lui faire payer
cher et c'est vrai que surtout avec ce
sentiment de sécurité qui progresse
enfin sentiment accompagnement une
cuisse en sentiments les chiffres chez
les chiffres de la délinquance par
personne depuis tout est rapide avec des
événements très symbolique alors
événements ou sécuritaires ou
judiciaires avec le fameux verdict
notamment vie riche être une vie dorée
châtillon tout ça fait résonnant dans
l'opinion donc élever une vraie
nécessité d'être présent sur 7 sur ce
terrain là pascal perrineau est ce que
les français ont confiance en emmanuel
macron sur ce sujet de la sécurité est
ce qu'il est crédible aux normes france
alors il faut être clair il n'est pas
crédible pour l'instant car il va
chercher à construire une crédibilité
mais les chiffres sont même des chiffres
tout à fait redoutable dans cette
enquête qui vient d'être faite sur le
terrain le regard des français sur la
délinquance on a posé la question en
france
avez vous le sentiment que ces derniers
mois la délinquance a augmenté 71%
donc voilà
donc ça touche en effet tous les
électorats toutes les tranches d'âge etc
et quant aux poses la question sur la
crédibilité du président et de l'action
du président guerrier vous que le bilan
des manuels macron depuis son élection
est positif ou négatif
en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
l'insécurité ces redoutables pour le
président 1 74%
trois français sur quatre on vous dise
voilà cet habile en négatif à française
comme vous vous rendez compte il n'y a
que dans l'électorat de la république en
marche comme considère pas ce qu'on à la
halle à la fois du militant que ça
marche mais à la france insoumise 80 2%
des électeurs de la france insoumise
considère que c'est négatif 80 73 % des
électeurs du ps 83 % des électeurs des
républicains et 96 % des électeurs du
rassemblement national dont vous voyez
ça fait beaucoup de gens à convaincre
mais sur la ligne de départ il part avec
un gros handicap un gros handicap fait
part avec seulement celle ci peut
poursuivre ce terrain là je pense qu
emmanuel macron ne paye pas tant son
bilan de président que son image
personnelle parce que c'est vrai que les
thématiques de sécurité d'immigration
talent ce qu'on appelle le régalien sens
large d'une herbe alors n'était pas un
domaine sur lequel ils étaient
identifiés lors de son arrivée en
politique se souvient même lors de face
aux attentats de 2015
manuel valls à l'intérieur puis à
matignon avait joué de ce contrat sac et
moniales bacon pour dévoiler moi je
prends ça au sérieux
l'huile pour lui avec une écurie très
social des questions de terrorisme
depuis qu'il est à l'elysée et dès le
début de son mandant pourtant emmanuel
macron a cherché à corriger ça et être
assez actif il a eu deux mises de trois
ministres de l'intérieur successifs
gérard collomb christophe castaner et
gérald darmanin je pense est
essentiellement un colon et à darmanin
qui l'un comme l'autre
d'emblée on sait de dôme et de données
pour ton image d' homme d'autorité de
vrais patrons de l'apple la police
souvenez vous la lui la loi collomb qui
avait été très critiquée à gauche et
quand une loi est critiquée à gauche et
que le président elle met en avant des
thèmes un peu un peu répressif ou un peu
merci tiff gérald darmanin a fortiori
depuis qu'il est là veut montrer avec
cette manière d'être présent si comme
l'était avant lui nicolas sarkozy
surtout les tous les évènements tout le
terrain d'action mettant en jeu la
question de sécurité
donc en termes d'actions et magnanac on
rappelle en figaro aussi les créations
d'effectifs dans la police dans la
gendarmerie
maintenant les places de prisons qui
s'engagent aussi à construire donc
devenir le bilan comptable
quelque part il est là mais lorsqu'on a
une image initiale c'est très très
difficile à corriger et je pense qu'il
ne suffira pas maintenant ou d'une
interview mais même chez nous ou de
quelques décisions en fin de mandat pour
changer radicalement une image qui est
kiné qui n'est pas bonne en la matière
alors pour poursuivre le débat je vous
propose d'écouter jérôme fourquet
directeur du département opinion de
l'ifop il parlait ce matin sur lci
sondage de nos confrères d'ipsos indiqué
que sur la question de la lutte contre
la délinquance quand on demande aux
français à qui font plus confiance entre
marine le pen emmanuel macron les écarts
sont tout à fait spectaculaire 45 % font
confiance à marine le pen contre 17%
seulement à emmanuel ma quant aux
convois pour revenir à votre question
initiale que si la campagne sera
orientée majoritairement sur les thèmes
sécuritaires alors là il y aura un
avantage structurel un avantage de
terrain pour marine le pen
guillaume tabard parler de sécurité
c'est pour emmanuel macron rattraper
aussi son retard sur marine le pen alors
c'est l'éternelle question lorsque l'on
met un sujet dans un débat est ce que
est ce qu'on rattrape à retard ou est ce
que on valide les les thèses de
l'adversaire ou dut ou du concurrent e
bon je n'ai pas la réponse que il ya
évidemment une nécessité d'être présent
sur ce terrain la nécessité de montrer
qu'il n'est ni naïf ni angéliques
inactifs sur ces thématiques de sécurité
de laïcité on en parle à tout à l'heure
ou d'immigration bon en terminant c'est
vrai que marine le pen par avec pour le
coup des thèmes identifiantes et on dit
souvent que dans un débat politique a
fortiori dans une campagne
présidentielle
le vainqueur est celui qui fixe l'agenda
des quais des thématiques sarkozy avait
très bien réussi à le faire
emmanuel macron avait réussi à le faire
aussi dans campagne 2010 est en parlant
de cette fameuse question de
l'émancipation individuelle ou même de
la rupture du du match droite gauche
c'est lui qui avait imposé ce thème de
campagne
là c'est vrai vous avez raison d'une
certaine manière il va sur le terrain
des adversaires alors que l'on voit sur
leur terrain est ce qu'on est capable de
les concurrencer
ou est ce concours sans fin derrière
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
rattraper ça c'est nora la réponse dans
un an
mais vous voyez que ça va être tout de
même extrêmement difficile pour le
président parce que d'abord il ya une
situation qu'on n'a jamais connu sous la
vème république qui est peu à peu le
cumul de différentes insécurité quelques
mois avant cette grande échéance de la
présidentielle je m'explique la sécurité
nouvelle bien sûr sanitaire est ce qu'on
en sera vraiment sorti à la fin de
l'année elle en effet pas évident c'est
pas sûr du tout évident l'insécurité
économique et social qui a déjà commencé
et tous les français s'attendent à ce
que ça augmente le chômage des jeunes la
difficulté que l'on constate aujourd'hui
des jeunes à rentrer sur le marché de
l'emploi les pme et les tpe qui ferme
etc qui ne rouvriront pas enfin il ya
une insécurité économique et social donc
majeur
1,6 à cette insécurité s'ajoute la
sécurité du quotidien le fait qu en
effet dans de multiples quartiers c'est
compliqué de se rendre à la banque pour
tirer quelques billets que lorsqu'on est
une jeune femme en effet ben voilà on
est soumis au mieux à de multiples
incivilités mais éventuellement à des
agressions
là vous voyez ce cumul d insécurité ça
peut être une véritable déflagration
politique il faut faire très attention
souvenons nous en 2002 pourtant le
contexte était plus paisible
économiquement et socialement
non beaucoup plus paisible voulait pas
les papilles voir il y avait eu en effet
ce fameux papy voise dans les quartiers
nord d'orléans qu'était un quartier de
l'argonne quartiers difficiles etc
on avait vu ce ce pauvre er avec le
visage totalement tuméfié parce qu'il
avait été tabassé par deux jeunes voyous
et ça avait marqué énormément la
campagne mais c'était l'arrivée 2 bravo
voilà c'est un des éléments parmi
d'autres mais c'est un des éléments
majeurs de la surprise le pen jean
marine le pen qui va s'inviter au second
tour donc voilà ce genre de situation
peut très bien se reproduire
surtout dans les chiffres à un an si
vous voulez la lutte contre la
délinquance c'est 69% des français qui
vous disent qu'ils vous disent que ce
sera prioritaire pour leur choix la
présidentielle voyez 69%
donc voilà ça n'aura pas besoin de
s'inviter c'est là déjà là c'est là pour
revenir
guillaume tabard à l'interview de
emmanuel macron accordé au figaro il dit
je n'ai pas en tête un quelconque agenda
politique je présiderai jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure j'agirai jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure alors pour plus tôt ce qui
en est le quelconque agenda politique
qui vraiment on peut le croire en tout
cas l'agenda politique nous on le
connaît on sait qu'il ya une phase
essentielle dans un an pile
liu se maintenant bon donc on ne va pas
lui faire injure de d'ignorer ce que
nous nous connaissons voilà ensuite
voilà je pense que un politique
lorsqu'il dit qu'il gît en ne se
souciant pas des de tout cela on n'est
pas toujours obligé de le voir enfin ce
qui est vrai mais ce qui ce qui est bien
la preuve qu'il est courant qui à cette
échéance politique c'est qui c'est qui
ne peut pas arriver avec un quelqu'un à
un quinquennat à l'arrêt parce que on
parle cette parenthèse du que vides
non c'est une chose c'est à dire
maintenant depuis un an ccef comme une
parenthèse salon mais avant il y avait
déjà eu la crise et gilet jaune qui de
manière avait mis aussi à l'arrêt un
grand nombre de réformes alors entre les
deux edouard philippe avec emmanuel
macron avec edouard philippe avait tenté
de lancer la réforme des retraites
poisson cette réforme elle reste
suspendu donc on pourrait arriver
dans un an avec ce paradoxe qu emmanuel
macron le présent réformateur par
excellence sera le seul président de
depuis mitterrand à ne pas voir réformer
les retraites
même françois hollande avait apporté sa
pierre à la réforme du financement des
retraites avec ce qu'on appellerait la
fameuse réforme touraine donc ce serait
quand même un paradoxe pour lui qu'il
arrive en ayant mis aux arrêts toutes
les réformes dont il a besoin de montrer
qu'ils continuent à réformer là c'est
délicat parce que le propre d'une
réforme c'est une vraie une réforme pour
qu'elle soit vraiment importante
il faut qu'elle soit un peu un peu
coûteuse et coûts qu'elles remettent en
cause des habitudes des camps d des
privilèges du conservatisme pourquoi
donc on ne fait pas ça on ne fait pas
d'omelette sans casser des oeufs
on ne réforme pas dans le consensus
absolu
donc il est partagée entre la nécessité
de ne pas se mettre à dos une population
qui a quand même été prouvée et
réellement éprouvées par tous ces crises
mme que l'on a vécu et que l'on travers
son corps et la nécessité de montrer que
il n'aura pas passé un an réformer et
quatre ans être empêtrés dans les crises
absolument allons voir du côté dons des
internautes ce qu'ils en pensent ludovic
sur twitter nous dit cela n'est qu'un
affichage à des fins politiques pour
flatter un électorat en vue de la
prochaine présidentielle jean-louis sur
youtube de la com comme d'habitude il
est en campagne son seul souci concerne
sa réélection alors que le pays va mal
et qu ils en portent une large
responsabilité générale et skype
s'il voulait faire un virage sécuritaire
il n'avait qu'à le faire dès le début de
son mandat
enfin david vu les levées de ces sortes
lors de ses sorties il n'est pas
seulement il n'est pas seulement non
crédible il est haï par le peuple
la question twitter que vous vous posez
êtes vous convaincu par le virage
sécuritaire des manuels macro et à 81 2%
vous nous dites que non une grosse
majorité oui c'est tout à fait en phase
avec ce que l'on recense dans l'opinion
publique
le travail pour le président sur ce
terrain à faire est énorme parce que
comme le disait guillaume tout à l'heure
ça n'a jamais été au coeur de ses
préoccupations dans sa campagne les
sujets vraiment régaliens
au fond il les découvre une fois qu'il
est en poste mais le candidat macron
n'était que très peu sensible alors ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ait rien fait
ou qu'il n'ait pas tenté d'agir sur ce
terrain régaliens mais on voit aussi
qu'il n'est pas très à l'aise et
pourtant il avait théorisé le président
jupitérien jupiter devrait s'intéresser
quelque peu aux affaires aux affaires
régaliennes mais on sent qu'il est qui
qu'il est mal à l'aise sur ce terrain
comme sur d'autres
celui de la laïcité dont on va parler à
petit est ce que je peux dire un mot
répondre à notre ami internaute sur la
question de ma place en fait il fait ça
uniquement pour raisons électorales mais
c'est l'éternel débat savez en politique
est ce qu on fait ça pour le bien du
pays
août parce qu'on est sociaux sa
réélection mais si le souci de la
rédaction est un moteur pour l'action et
donc pour le bien du pays
en un sens pour mieux gérer ici notre
internaute et est soucieux de paroles de
fermeté en matière de
de sécurité il vaut mieux même si ça et
xavière pensée politique que et magnolia
qu'on les tienne plutôt qu'ils ne les
tiennent pas il faut mieux qu'il prenne
des décisions allant dans ce sens plutôt
qu'ils ne fassent rien absolument allez
on passe à un autre second sujet laïcité
des états généraux pour quoi faire alors
marlène schiappa ministre délégué chargé
de la citoyenneté a lancé ce matin les
états généraux de la laïcité
l'idée c'est de débattre avec des
intellectuels de lancer une grande
consultation entre est de 50 mille
jeunes ça va durer trois mois et on aura
une restitution avant l'été alors pascal
perrineau
hier donc dans le figaro emmanuel macron
oppose un pion sur sa droite avec la
question de la sécurité
ce matin marlène schiappa et la laïcité
c'est un pion peser à gauche c'est une
façon aussi de fracture et à gauche oui
ça dépasse très nettement la gauche
parce que au fond la question de la
laïcité ça touche tout simplement au
lien social en france conduit le lien
social j'allais dire au contrat citoyen
jusqu'à maintenant on a fait citoyenneté
en france en respectant ce que l'on
pourrait appeler presque le pacte laïc
de la loi de 1905 revu et corrigé et au
fond là ça s'adresse certes à la gauche
mais ça s'adresse aussi à la droite
alors ça s'adresse peut-être un peu plus
à la gauche parce que la gauche et
travailler aujourd'hui par une remise en
cause du modèle de la laïcité qui
pourtant a été historiquement un un de
ses éléments constituants et là on
s'aperçoit qu'ils à côté de la gauche
qu'on pourrait être qualifié de gauche
républicaine qui existe toujours qu'à de
grandes figures
je pense en particulier par exemple à
jean pierre chevènement un ministre qui
était très proche de françois mitterrand
comme jean glavany on pourrait comme ça
multiplier de grandes figures de cette
gauche républicaine et bien est apparue
une gauche qu'on pourrait qualifier d'
un peu communautariste et même de plus
en plus communautariste et on le voit
c'est à la base du diagnostic que manuel
valls avait tiré sur ces deux gauches
irréconciliables
parce que de ceux ci voulaient est ce
que la gauche envoie véritablement au
magasin des accessoires
l'idée d'une laïcité d'une laïcité qui
se fait respecter pas simplement de
vagues principes de la laïcité des
pratiques de laïcité et là on voit que
la gauche est aujourd'hui extrêmement
divisé sur ce terrain qu'elle n'arrivera
pas se réconcilier et que d'ailleurs je
crois c'est un des éléments aujourd'hui
de la difficulté de la gauche a trouvé
un candidat qui leur permettrait
d'accéder au second tour
ils ne peuvent pas parce qu'ils ne sont
d'accord sur rien landi très souvent sur
rien d'un point de vue économique et
social mais sur rien là sur le terrain
des valeurs c'est là c'est beaucoup plus
gênant 1 parce que entre certains grands
leaders républicains de la gauche et la
gauche communautariste particulièrement
sensibles par exemple les filles au npa
dans une partie du parti socialiste
chez les verts voilà vous avez un
conflit sur les valeurs et qui fait que
cette gauche n'arrivera jamais à trouver
son centre de gravité parce qu'elle l'a
perdu quelque part elle l'a perdue et
puis on se souvient je voulais vous
faire réagir là-dessus aussi guillaume
tabard d'une enquête ifop parue en mars
qui montrait que plus d'un lycéen sur
deux se dit favorable au port de signes
religieux ostensibles dans les lycées
publics un essai deux fois plus que dans
l'ensemble de la population population
c'est peut-être ce qui a motivé aussi
fait ce qui motive ma louis pas à parler
à et convaincre les jeunes générations
bien en tout cas ça va je pense que la
question de la laïcité en tant que telle
est un vrai sujet émérite mérite un vrai
débat
mais bon ne serait ce que pour définir
ce qu'est la laïcité est ce que la
laïcité c'est refuser toute affirmation
religieux dans une société
ça a été
tant les combats d'une certaine gauche
die karmapa dans le vieux modèle de 35
c'était le petit père combes bon ou est
ce que la laïcité c'est de permettre au
contraire là le respect de toutes les
croyances dans un cadre commun et
acceptée par tous c'est la laïcité
version aristide briand et qui s'est
imposé avec le en tout cas la la la la
manière dont elle a été voulue simple à
appliquer la loi de 1905 donc que le
débat soit réel c'est une chose et qu'il
faille en débattre et de manière si
possible apaisé pourquoi pas moi il ya
plusieurs points kim qui m'interrogent
un peu le premier c'est quand même la
question du calendrier parce que si on
voulait sourire un peu tentés qu'on
puisse juger que ce serait à kindu le
sait on peut dire va très bien faisons
des états généraux de la laïcité
discussions discutons-en et puis une
fois qu'on aura terminé ce débat
pourquoi ne ferait on pas une loi sur
les principes républicains
oui oui c'est toi on vient de la voter
donc son veut un vrai débat de fond qui
soit trancher ensuite par la loi ou on
fait une loi non pas dans l'urgence que
entre le moment où il maniait mac on a
parlé première fois et puis il son vote
il ya quand même de longs mois donc le
débat il n'aurait pas avoir lieu
là ça fait un peu séance de rattrapage
alors soit il ya des arrière-pensées
strictement politique et pascal terry
dont le souligner la volonté d' emmanuel
macron et marlène schiappa est assez sur
ce terrain-là de pointer les
contradictions internes à la gauche
bon ça c'est la logique politique et ça
en fait partie et pour jaillir pour
pourquoi pas mais sinon voilà à quoi
c'est vraiment ce débat et on va dire
que
y compris à tradition de la halle où on
voit bien que il ya en fait une
difficulté à nommer clairement les
choses parce qu en fait soyons clairs
skis après mme de laïcité en france
aujourd'hui
non il ya un problème spécifique de la
manière dont l'islam qui qui qui
progresse numériquement et ça c'est une
réalité en tant que tel trouve sa place
ou non dans la société d'une part et
dans la république d'autre part et on
voit bien que il ya des points de
frottement et que au sein même de
l'islam il ya différentes sensibilités
est certain c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'islamisme qui traduit cela en un
véritable projet politique qui est un
projet de combat contre la république
telle qu'on la vit aujourd'hui près de
la cité ne concerne pas aujourd'hui ni
catholiques les protestants et les juifs
ou toute autre forme d'autres de de
croyance et jacques sauquet en agitant
ce mot de laïcité de manière un peu à
considère 20 considéré en tout cas
indéfinie bon on est un voile pudique
sur un problème concret qui est celui de
l'islamisme à laquelle la loi a voulu
répondre mais voilà et que pour pas
valeur de cibler une communauté
particulière on va envelopper ça devient
plus grave avec le risque de deux balles
perdues comme on l'a vu avec le débat
sur la loi la loi séparatisme est là en
effet on touche à quelque chose
d'extrêmement important parce qu'à force
de ceux de cacher le véritable problème
qui est la question de l'islam et de la
dérive d'une partie minoritaire mais
très active de l'islam vers une volonté
qu'à partir de la question religieuse
on se pose la question de la prise du
pouvoir politique
si on dit les choses clairement c'est le
projet des islamistes donc il n'y a pas
de raison de ne pas les prendre au
sérieux
mais on voit bien que ça contamine de
manière extrêmement perverses le débat
moi il ya un exemple je viens de finir
la lecture d'un petit livre qui a été
tout même écrit après la terrible le
terrible meurtre de samuel pâtit donc
professeur
qui à partir d'une réflexion de ses
élèves sur les caricatures de charlie
voulait poser la question de l'islam de
ce que l'islam peut admettre dans la vie
politique et culturelle française et un
professeur je crois au collège de france
françois héran a écrit de manière très
docte une lettre aux enseignants pour
donner son message aux enseignants sur
ce qu'il faudrait faire et qui est une
critique à peine voilée de ce café
samuel pâti dans sa classe g dire voyez
et où il explique de manière extrêmement
docte que la liberté aujourd'hui que la
liberté de croyance alors de croyances
pour les musulmans ça c'est le non dit
un de croyance est plus important que la
liberté d'expression
bon attention là je vais dire quand on
commence sur ce chemin on connaît une
véritable dérive et c'est ce que
j'appelle les dérives de cette gauche
communautariste parce que à droite là le
comment dire la dérive communautariste
et beaucoup plus même les presque
totalement marginal mais dans une partie
d'eux des forces qui soutiennent
emmanuel macron des forces qui
soutiennent l'écologie et des forces qui
soutiennent la gauche et l'extrême
gauche la dérive est à l'oeuvre et oui
il y à des convergences entre des
franges intégriste de l'islam des
branches fondamentalisme de l'islam et
des forces militantes de la gauche qui
jadis se battait bec et ongles pour la
défense d'une laïcité même d'une laïcité
alors c'était très bien quand il
s'agissait comme on disait de bouffer du
curé
mais quand il s'agit si vous me
permettez vous fait de l'imam radical là
ça devient beaucoup plus difficile donc
finalement quand même quelque part même
si on peut se poser la question quand
même du calendrier
ces états généraux feint d'avoir quand
même un débat sur la laïcité c'est quand
même intéressant après faut voir ça par
sa débauche que moi j'ai en tête deux
exemples de grands débats comme ça
qu'ils étaient censés aussi dénouer des
questions en jeu un peu piégé il ya eu
pour prendre le plus proche
chronologiquement le les états généraux
de la bioéthique était censée préparer
la loi de bioéthique états généraux ont
été abondamment suivi dans le dans le
pays a par exemple peut-être par des
gens qui sentaient plus concernées mais
en tout cas et une très forte
participation et les agents sont arrivés
à des conclusions qui était aux
antipodes de ce qui s'est traduit 20
lois bioéthiques alors après on peut
dire que le que les chateurs et
souverain gouvernement fait ce qu'il
veut très bien mais il y avait au moins
ce déphasage entre ce que l'opinion en
tout cas qui s'étaient intéressés à ces
sujets avaient dit et ce qui a été
décidé après donc à smara des états
généraux pour quoi faire
et puis l'autre exemple c'était quand
même si ce grand débat national voulu
par nicolas sarkozy sur l'identité
nationale quelque part faire des états
généraux sur la laïcité c'est aussi une
manière de dire interrogeons nous sur ce
qu'est l'identité nationale alors
absolument y est les mots moi je suis
pour qu'on est tous les débats et je
pense car aucun tabou à voir il faut
pouvoir tout mettre sur la table
après ce sont les arrière pensées et les
transformations du débat peut-être que
nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas été non plus
très clair sur ce qu'ils voulaient
vraiment à travers ce grand débat sur
l'identité nationale certains lui ont
fait le reproche de vouloir mener une
campagne déguisée contre l'islam
mon résultat il a dû plier les gaules et
ceux des bananes est strictement à rien
on soit dire qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
français c'est un débat qui est noble et
qui était nécessaire mais il a été mal
enclenché et donc il n'avait abouti sur
rien il faudrait pas que ce débat sur la
laïcité qui pourraient plus aussi
nécessaire aboutissent au même résultat
c'est très dommage un colon mais ces
grands débats fondamentaux pour l'avenir
du pays en période électorale c'est la
pire des périodes pour les avoir eus
allons voir ce qu'on pense donc les
internautes nos internautes camille
c'est ridicule il ya des priorités bien
plus majeur que ces choses inutiles
comme une certaine menace sanitaire
gisèle nous avons tout un arsenal
juridique sur ce sujet qui n'est pas
utilisée dans corps du flan etienne la
laïcité c'est certes accordé des droits
mais s'est aussi imposé des devoirs
comme dans tous les domaines
d'ailleurs et puis à un internaute qui
s'appelle une autre laïcité point
d'interrogation on ne sait plus ce que
veut dire ce mot tellement il a été
galvaudé d'où le malaise et la question
twitter qu'on vous a posé pensez vous
que les états généraux de la laïcité
seront utiles vous répondez non à 83%
voilà ce qu'en disent nos internautes eh
bien écoutez point de vue c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui merci chers internautes
de nous avoir suivis merci à nous
inviter pascal perrineau et guillaume
tabard et on se retrouve demain même
heure et même endroit
[Musique]